[موسيقى]
مساء الخير او الاول خلينا نقول بقى مساء
الخير على الناس اللي كانت جايبه مجموع
عالي الثانويه العامه وقدره يدخلوا كليه
من كليات القمه
اما بقى الناس الثانيين اللي زي دول بتوع
البزنس في اهلا بكم
خليني الاول بقى اسال سؤال كده عايز اعرف
الناس اللي كانوا جايبين 88 مثلا 95 99.9
في ناس بتعمل 103 ما اعرفش ازاي ياريت
اي جي 9
ما اعرفهاش يعني يا ريت بقى اي حد
انتم بقى منورين جامعه النيل وقفوني في اي
وقت اي سؤال
طيب خلينا نتكلم دلوقتي او نبدا كلامنا هو
اصلا يعني ايه كليه قمه ومين اللي قال ان
في حاجه اسمها كليه جمه وهل المسمى عشان
حاجه معينه وهل الكلام ده في مصر بس ولا
اقول
في الاول خالص لما اجي اسالك دلوقت يعني
ايه كليه قمه ده المفروض الكليه اللي انا
ادخلها ده انت شلني من الفقر والمجاعه
وتحطني جنب ابو هشيمه وسويرس ولا الناس
للسؤال اللي بعديه هو اصلا يعني ايه قمه
يعني لو احنا سالنا بعد دلوقتي او سالنا
100 شخص من الناس اللي موجوده
يعني ايه قمه هنلاقي مين ديفينيشن مختلفه
وكلهم صح بكل بساطه لان انا عبد الفتاح
ممكن يكون مثلا تعريف القمه بالنسبه لي ان
انا وصلت لبوزشن معين ممكن حضرتك مثلا
القمه بالنسبه لك توصل لفلوس معينه حد
ثالث بالنسبه له قمه ان هو يوصل لوضع
مجتمعي او يبقى عنده
يعني يبقى له سلطه معينه فبالتالي اصلا
تعريف القمه نسبي فبالتالي هيبقى صعب جدا
ان انا اقول القمه اللي هي ديفينيشن
السؤال الثاني هل الكلام ده في مصر بس ولا
في العالم كله خليني اقول لكم الكلام ده
في ام الدنيا بس ليه بقى لان كل بساطه في
2020 امريكا دي دوله طبعا متقدمه زينا في
امريكا
انا محتاج ان انا اجوز روق اساس منسي اقدر
اتاكد مدى فهمي لجاست سكربشن بتاعي ومدى
فهم من سوق العمل ليه لان انا بكل بساطه
ممكن اكون راجل متخرج من كليه كبيره جدا
بس عندي عقد نفسيه فما تقرفناش دي حاجه طب
حاجه ثانيه في حاجه اسمها جوجل جرير مين
هنا يا ياسر اسمع عن حاجه اسمها جوجل كبير
الناس اللي رفعت ايديها عارفين جوجل كبير
عملت حاجه ان انت بتدخل تدرس لمده سته
شهور بتاخذ سيرتك معينه من جوجل بتقدر
بيها بتستغنى عن اصلا الكليه ممكن تشتغل
في جوجل وعلى فكره تقدروا تعملوا ده من
دلوقت تقدر تشتغل في اي دوله من الدول
المتقدمه بس ترتديت فبتغني عن الكليه
بتاعتك طيب
خليني عايز اقول لكم على حاجه ثانيه كده
خالص الحاجه دي مهمه جدا لازم كلنا تركز
فيها ان احنا مهم جدا نركز وقمه كويسه وكل
سنه وانتم طيبين والف الف مبروك
حسيته بايه دلوقتي من اللي انا قلته ده
اتقفلت صح طب ايه اللي اتغير اللي اتغير
دلوقتي حالا الطريقه اللي انا كنت بتكلم
بها فبالتالي ده هياخذنا لحاجه ثانيه اللي
اتغير دلوقتي هو السوفت ان كوميكشن سكولز
اللي اتقال دلوقتي حالا بطريقه قفلتك او
حسيت ايه ده هو تعبان ولا ايه
طيب خلينا نقول هل
الحاجه دي مهمه يعني الكلام ده هل هو مهم
طب مين هنا خريج كليه سوفت سكيلز كوميكيشن
سكيلز
ما فيش كليه
طب الناس بتوع الكليات اللي هم بيسموها
كليات القمه هل في ماده بيدرسها اسمها
اكيد دي مش مهمه خليني اقول لكم بقى ان
تقريبا ما فيش حاجه مهمه زي ده
سؤال ثاني ايه اكثر مجال تقريبا بيبقى فيه
فلوس
خلينا نقول تقريبا كده سيل صح طيب
مجال السيلز كله تقريبا قايم على كوميكشن
سكاليز
طيب هل في كليه اسمها كليه
اسمها كليه ما فيش
لون جهاز تكلمنا عن السيلز وتكلمنا عن
سكيلز وتكلمنا عن الحاجات الحلوه دي كلها
اكثر شاهد على كده اخواتنا السوريين اللي
هتلاقوا مثلا لو انت دخلت مثلا اي محمصه
او حاجه تدخل المكان مش عايز تخرج منه انا
بس مع جوه كلام ما بسمعوش من مراتي اهلا
بك مبلغ
[موسيقى]
طب انا دفعت الفلوس دي ليه الدنيا عملت
معي كده ليه من الاخر علشان فن اختيار
الكلام
هل الكلام ده
مختصره فقط على حاجه بعينها يعني على كليه
بعينها اطلاقا فبالتالي ما فيش حاجه اسمها
كليه قمه وكليه قاع القمه وقاع هنا
لو انت عندك معينه والله هو واتقابر وريفر
انت موجود فين وبتدرس ايه يكون ماجد لان
البساطه ربنا ده انا وهبنا حاجه حلوه قوي
ان النجاح مش تمليك النجاح هو ايجار هو
ايجاره بتدفعوا كل يوم
طيب خلينا نروح لنقطه ثانيه كده هل الكلام
بقى اللي عبد الفتاح بيقولوا دلوقتي بيقول
ان كليه الهندسه مثلا طب سياسه واقتصاد
والحاجات دي كلها مش مهمه طبعا لا مهمه
وليها تقديرها والشهادات مهمه جدا علشان
كده هنلاقي مثلا او مش هنقول ان في ناس
ومشاهير كثير جدا هنتكلم عليهم في السلايد
اللي بعديها اصلا مش معاهم شهاده جماعيه
بس قبل ما نروح للسلايد دي خلينا نشوف
دلوقت الصوره ديت شايفين ايه قدامكم
باب باب شكله حلو قوي باب شيك مصروف عليه
جدا بس خليني اقول لكم ان هو
ولا ليه اهميه من غير ايه من غير المفصلات
اللي في الاجناب دي انا مش نجار
خلينا نقول ان الباب ده تقريبا
شويه كده ان في بعض الناس
زي مارك ذكر بيرك بيل جيتس جيم كاري ستيف
جوبز وانا كنت باعمل استغربت ازاي الناس
دي كده ايوه هو الناس دي اصلا في البدايه
خالص مكنتش معاها شهاده جامعيه طيب هل ده
معناه ان الشهاده مش مهمه طبعا مهمه عشان
بس ما حدش يقول عبد الفتاح قال مش مهمه لا
هي طبعا مهمه ولكن مش هي اللي هتنجحك
لوحدها خلينا نقول مثلا مثال هنفهم به
اكثر اللي انا عايز اقوله
انا اول ما بشوف المنظر ده باحس ان انا
انا داخل على حاجه حلوه يعني
طيب مين هنا بياكل او بيحب ماكدونالدز
عشان هو احلى طعم او احلى برجر في مصر
طيب
ماكدونالدز
في مصر بس في نفس الوقت هو مش احلى برجر
في مصر
من انجح الناس في الفيل بتاعي او في
المكان بتاعي من غير ما يبقى داخل اعلى
كليه وجايب اعلى شهاده اه
هي معي ماكدونالدز كده شاب
دخل جامعه اسمها الاف بي
او المطاعم والاسف ما توفقش ما جابش درجه
عاليه جدا فدخل كليه عاديه اسمها
برجر وبرده متوفقش بجد مجموعه عادي
يسكت لا ينجح ازاي بكل بساطه هو شاف هو
فين عمل حاجه اسمها انا فين عايز اروح فين
اروح ازاي اتاكد منين ان انا وصلت
ماكدونالدز ركز جدا لو تلاحظوا على
الفروقات او ان هو ادبليو دارس السوق خلي
الناس ايموشن مرتبطين به اشتغل جدا على
السوشيال انتلجنس
ماكدونالدز
خطيره انا بجوع صح انا بعمل
خطيره مضمون الكلام ده ان انا مش شرطه
تكون انجح
بشهادتي عشان انجح لا يوهاتي
حاجه كل شيء شويه
الراجل المحترم ده
محمد صلاح
عشان امبارح
105 من مواطن مصر تكلموا فيها
اتكلموا فيها ايه هي الرجل دوت
والمهاجم اللي جنبه ده
يعني مش هنحسده
هي دي شهاده والملعب
هو ده سوق العمل
ايه الفاليو اللي حضرتك هتقدم لها شهاده
كده ايه الفاليو اللي حضرتك هتقدمها
هتزود سعرك الراجل دوت تعرض زي اي احد في
الناس اللي قاعده في مصر
وياخذ فلوس برده بس هو عنده فيجن
علينا بالضبط
اي حد فينا لازم ياخد باله من الحاجات
اللي بتنجح مش بس الشهاده لازم اركز جدا
ان انا يبقى عندي السوفت كوميركشن سكيلز
عندي سوشي عندي ايموشن لازم كل واحد فينا
لو انا لسه في الجامعه في سنه اولى تانيه
تالته رابعه عشره ايا كان ركز جدا لازم
تدخل اكثر من وورد شوب سكول شوب لازم تاخذ
ترينز كثير كورسز اون لاين علشان لما تطلع
لسوق العمل وقال لك لا لا ما توقعش
لان كده كده هيتقلك لا ما حدش فينا بيتعلم
ركوب العجل من على اليوتيوب لازم تركب مره
وتقع تتعور ثاني
تتكسر لحد ما تعيط وعادي جدا تعيط بس لما
تعيط تعيط بشرطتين الشرط الاول مش قدام حد
عيب بينك وبين نفسك مش بس اللي دراسه
الشخصيه قدام الناس انت اقوى واحد في
العالم في الكون رقم اثنين السبب اللي انت
هتعيط عليه هيعيط عليه مره واحده عليه
مرتين بس كده
فلما تطلع نسوق العمل خلاص راجل خرجت ابقى
جاهز
وعارفرسايكل لا علشان زي ما قلنا كده كده
سوق العمل مش هيقول لك لا ده هيديك 100
قلم اللي هيجيء في وشك بقى هتاخذه وانت
ماشي الفكره كلها
بالضبط كلها
ازاي لما تيجي تاخذ لكمه ازاي اعرف اصدها
واردها بوحده ثانيه
اخر حاجه
انا عشتها تجربه كده الموضوع انا قبل ما
ادخل مجال الريل ستيت كنت شغال في البنك
كينج سيكتور
من فتره كبيره كان تقريبا بيعاملونا كاننا
واكيد نيابه يعني لو حد كسر عليك عبد
الفتاح
كبيره
الحمد لله كانت الامور ماشيه كويس تلاقي
واحد صاحبي قعد سنه يتحايل عليا تعالى
تعالى
هو شغال بيورد انتاج وحاجات لها علاقه
بالصناعات والكلام ده كله وقال لي خساره
في مصر التجربه
ورحت رمان
وكنت رايح مدير بتاع تجاري لشركه بدون ذكر
اسمها من اكبر الشركات هناك
وطبعا العربيه لها سواق قاعد في الفيلا
حابب اشاركهم برده شكل الفيلا
دي الفيلا
اللي انا كنت فاكر اني اروح الاقيها بس
الحقيقه
[موسيقى]
خالص
دي اول ضربه في الفيلا كان المفروض اقعد
فيه بعد ما نظفها
بعد ماجبنا واسطه اتنقلت مع كبير العمال
ما فيهاش مراتب لو تلاحظوا
ودي بقى
قبل العيد
من بره طيب موت
تحول دوده اتصرف طيب انا باقول لكم ده ليه
باقول لكم دوت لان فعلا انا من وجهه نظري
شايف ان التجربه دي لما انا رحت كان عندي
اوبشن 2 اوبشن اللي فعليا ساعتها كان ممكن
ان انا اتدمر نفسيا ومعنويا وكل حاجه
لان الصوره اللي جايه دي صورتي ما بين
عمان والامارات لما صاحبي قال لي طب خلاص
سيب الشغل في الشركه ديت لان انا لقيت ان
الاقامه مش طالعه لي من غير قطعته جاري
الاقامه طالعه لي بقى عامل محاره
ليه بقى لان انا ما رجعتش كل ده لان لي
واحد صاحبي اللي هناك ده ربنا يكرمه
فمراجعتش كل العقود وكل الكلام ده كله
فبالتالي قال لي يلا بينا نروح طب
الامارات معايا واشتغل معايا في الامارات
رحت الامارات ما ينفعش اعدي من معبر لان
انا مش معايا اقامه فصاحبي ربنا يكرمه
سابني على المعبر هو راح الامارات وانا
كنت واقف على الطريق
سلام
25/04/2018 الساعه 3:00 الفجر قعدت ساعه
لحد لما عايز تروح فين
بس انا ما كنتش عارف انا فين لان انا رفضت
اقعد في المكان ده
فقعدنا نلف بقى بالشبه المكان ده فيه هنا
فيه صخر عامله كذا وفي كذا كذا
الحقيقه وانا باخذ الصوره دي انا كنت
باخدها وانا بضحك قبل ما الموبايل هيفصل
على طول كنت بضحك ليه لان اي دو بيليف ان
ربنا عمره ما بيضيع تعب اي حد وعندي ثقه
الحمد لله كبيره جدا في نفسي والحمد لله
الضحكه دي كنت واثق ان هيجي يوم زي اللي
انا واقف قصاد حضراتكم فيه الحمد لله اكبر
شركه ومن اكبر شركه
للريال في مصر اشكركم على طبيعتكم شكرا
[تصفيق]